[Music]  Candyman the urban legend is if you say  his name five times by looking in the  mirror he appears in the reflection and  it kills you who would do that  Candyman Candyman Candyman well we're  still alive let's go  Chino you broke the door  I feel really connected to this  neighborhood Cabrini Green was the  project's that just moved in around the  corner they all candy factory I'm an  artist you look up the Candyman he's the  monster it's part of this neighborhood  why are you drawn to this I'm hoping to  spray the story all about Candyman the  mirror invites uses summon him you  should say his name I dare you  Candyman Candyman Candyman Candyman  don't say - candy me  [Music]  I think it made a mistake  I'll cover the back  something's happening to me  he had purpose for you to be another one  of his terrible stories  perfect  [Music]  [Music]  you